Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg and his
wife Priscilla Chan nothing dumb about
them want to expand their reach beyond
the social media empire their
philanthropic company turns four years
old today that's the same age as her
oldest daughter will explain why a
little bit later its awarding millions
of dollars to projects like eliminating
all disease transforming criminal
justice and improving equity in
education we spoke with them at the
offices of the Chan Zuckerberg
initiative for their first ever joint
Network TV interview about what they
want to accomplish and they think big we
also asked them about calls to break up
Facebook you lead a company that has
great power and great influence should
one person or one company have that much
power so I think that the basic answer
what you're saying is no you say no yeah
private companies should not be in the
position of making so many important
decisions balancing different social
values that we all care about I think
the real answer is for there to be
regulation and he welcome regulation
absolutely
mark you say you welcome regulation
people say I'll give you some regulation
let's break up Facebook well I think
that there are real issues I think a lot
of people are upset and are talking
about measures like breaking up the
company that are actually going to fix
these issues right when Britain up
Facebook isn't going to address there
the question of political discourse one
of the things that we can do well
Facebook weathers its political storm
Zuckerberg and his wife Priscilla Chan
are steering their Facebook dollars
toward a different port the Chan
Zuckerberg initiative nicknamed czi it's
a couple's ambitious foray into
philanthropy how many employees do you
have here about 400 it turns four years
old today there are a lot of
philanthropies that try to bring capital
right and help fund important work but
there weren't that many that have the
capability to build tools to empower
different folks who are on the front
lines teachers doctors scientists we
don't have the right tools to do that
and mark has such an incredible
experience of building tools building
those tools won't be cheap so the couple
has promised to give the initiative 99%
of their personal wealth mostly in the
form of Facebook stock
at the time of the launch that was worth
about forty five billion dollars one of
the promises that you gave was you want
to eliminate all diseases and I heard
that anyway what we're not going to do
that ourselves you know we do think that
it will be possible to cure prevent or
be able to manage all diseases by the
end of this century it just sounded so
fantastical and so pie in the sky
setting audacious goals is important and
we need to think about beyond what's
possible you want to map every single
cell in the human body yes you would
think that we already know all the cells
and what they do have and the thing is
we don't and we need a reference so if
we unlock every single cell what will we
learn so I just think of this is a very
basic building block for a lot of
biological research to happen on top of
that but CGI's work extends beyond
science it's also funding projects in
the fields of criminal justice reform
and education which just so happens to
be one of Chan's many careers one of the
first things that she said to me was ok
we're gonna work together in education
you need to go be a teacher somewhere
and I was like I can teach you're
running this company it was like there's
no way that we're gonna do this work
together if you don't get some
experience doing this so I started this
after-school program on entrepreneurship
why did you think it was important for
him to do that one it's so rewarding and
to it it makes you feel what you read in
the news in a visceral way yeah and I
want you to have that deep gut feeling
of like this is critical it's one thing
to want to help other people's kids but
having your own changes everything and
that's why the letter announcing the
birth of their initiative came just days
after the birth of the couple's first
daughter max the legend has it that you
are literally editing the letter while
Priscilla's in labor at that time
retrospect not my best thing
it's easy I was truly born because of
once he became parents did you start
looking at the world differently
yeah I think when you're about to have a
new child it's just you're so filled
with hope about how things can go and
you're trying to assemble the crib and
you think I need to - you really want to
work - to remove anything that's gonna
hurt your child listen they both think
outside the box they both cheer each
other on and they're always thinking big
about how to change the world and they
want they want to make a difference and
clearly they both have already done that
she's a very very smart cookie
pediatrician by trade and it certainly
brought out in another side of him that
a lot of people their personal wealth or
that punish lot that's a lot of dollars
that's a lot of dollars there are those
that they should go into taxes own the
democratic say they did a wealth tax
come up at all mmm well I was talking to
them yes no it didn't kill you no no no
I didn't bring that out all right
grounds yeah we covered it we can't talk
about everything but next time if they
do it I will bring it up by promise